hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to one of the stranger games
that I've ever played called hot dog
heartache so well there's really not a
whole lot to explain for this you
proceed to run space to jump v2 kick the
[ __ ] out of enemies and yes that's about
all I got from the game so we're just
gonna so you're trying not to die
obviously and this is one of those
challenging platformer games but I seem
to be doing okay so far one thing that
really disturbs me is the music of it
it's very weird and at the same time it
kind of reminds me of earthbound if any
of you ever bladers but like um I forget
what the the the the area was called are
with the UM mr. Saturn the mr. Saturn
area I don't know why but I'm very much
reminded of that area just from the
music alone so for nostalgia purposes I
guess it's okay but other than that holy
crap okay so anyway what you trying to
do is these boxes help you get up high
so I need to get on the damn box get on
the other side of it yep yep Pepa so I
can kick with my little hotdog foot
because everyone knows in hotdogs have
feet and have motivation to run through
a world full oh I wasn't supposed to do
that probably oh well whatever who cares
barrel Shetty's I don't know why a
hotdog would be running from a butcher's
cleavers forks and knives because as far
as I know don't you eat hotdogs with
your hands at least that's what we do in
America hear us fat Americans slobs we
love art I died and I leaked out mustard
and ketchup how doesn't make any sense
how did they even get me I'm not exactly
sure
okay so eventually this game is supposed
to get like hard or something I don't
know you know what I'm not even gonna
bother killing him I died I barely
touched him
but you know what just get out of my way
I kicked him okay never mind then I got
to take this slow and actually try to
defeat them with my stupid box here get
out of the way no no aah
so if I just take it slow and kick him I
should be fine yep
I didn't know that and uh pep-pep
there we go yep yep nope okay so as far
as an objective to this game however I'm
not exactly sure what you guys are
looking for it's a game called hotdog
hero and I'm playing a hotdog so I don't
know what you want from me
[ __ ] come on I didn't die that was
stupid yeah and I pointed my butt so I
can understand that I'm trying to try to
get through this I'm not trying to hurry
in that I'm trying oh come on
I can't barely do it kicking the boxes
so haphazard and slow but if I had just
done this normally the first time I
would have been through this already so
it's my fault it's my fault game is dumb
it's my fault that I'm oh come on
goddamn al okay everyone
aggravated cuz I'm short oh I thought I
died that time for some reason running
over the fork on the ground okay so I
lose that there and then I gotta move to
the barrel anyway oh yeah yeah stay back
stay back from me just a delicate little
I know you're hurt where'd my barrel
there it is okay okay so obviously
graphically this game is not that come
on ah buh buh this bow last ball here
hell's going on here come on my head
itches time for any of it
I'm on a pressing schedule today because
the way my family does Christmas is
because um I do Christmas at my stepmoms
and my mom so um my stepmoms doing
Christmas today and I have to be there
and I'm short on time to record this
ding dong damn video I've been working
on this ha ha ha that's pow why
our head is a small little baloney and
Marquis all mixed together but anyway my
family does my other family I guess as
Christmas today so I got to record this
and I've been working really hard on
this other project that you guys are
going to like me and was a box go right
over his head that's so stupid this is
the bullies blast pool I've ever seen
toilet this isn't even hard is it not
cooperating why would the box sometimes
go flying ten fifty thousand feet in the
air like that what caused that okay ah
another ball ah I hate this I hate this
game No why would it go over is Adam why
would it go over that that time don't
like this oh oh I'm not going back for
its goods good kick the ball dodgeball
is the bully stuff bull I can't do
anything there's a frickin frackin box
decides to go behind me the box physics
needs some serious work game developer I
mean oh come on just cooperate with a is
the second goddamn level second level
second level god dingus damn it yeah
okay okay
kick oh come on you know why don't I
just jump over that would seem like the
best solution to everything
why have I not been I did I you son of a
[ __ ] I'm jumping over good through this
and screw this I should not be having
why is that what happened why did that
fork go flying across the room what
caused that to happen
hey Deb really dump kick okay you go
over there excuse me part apologizing
I've no chili hot dogs clogging my Rd I
jumped I jumped without stupid I hate
this game so much yeah on my way yeah my
way
No
stupid I'm not this isn't hard but for
some reason I am not able to get through
it I shouldn't have spent the past five
minutes on this Wow
I can't it's not fair I know I'm not
using the box but you guys still on the
box didn't work
screw you guys got my way I my way all
your blood ketchup go all over the place
I don't care why would that happen did
you guys see that why would that happen
uh I've been yelling way too much it's
way too early to be yelling this much
but I mean come on
this is such bull ass ball come on lose
my mind this way to room my dad is a
freakin Fork
I couldn't ah now I'm very upset right
now
this is bull why is this happening
Oh God jingis damn you guys
alright that was my fault that was the
only one that was actually my fault
there cuz I jumped right into his blade
but I mean nothing that everything else
has not been my fault yeah there we go
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah jump over
them and then you jump and then use the
barrel to my event if you really want me
to use this barrel then why the hell are
you making it so hard for me and I just
push it is that something that I could
have done there from the beginning there
oh I'm such an [ __ ] I am such an
idiot
wow look at me all right [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
you get behind it [ __ ] goddamn it
ah God my blood pressure should not be
going up this pie is early in the
morning it is like way early for me to
be raising this heart I'm sorry
everybody I'm really trying the Winston
I'm not trying to lose I hate how I hate
it when people like now you're just
trying to lose that makes me angry
No
you think I want to do that no not even
a little bit
Oh anyway how am I supposed to do that I
guess you could jump kick yeah like that
[ __ ] get out here good girl Asti is
easy well this is easy now up oh that
was a mistake
yeah then I spray my ketchup and mustard
all over the bleep yep
gotcha oh come on I made that before
hip-hip ease here we go okay so now what
I got to do is I think I gotta kick the
box oh wow
I gotta kick the box into this pit and
then jump on to it
oh that does not help me I might be just
enough yeah
so this is more fair at least the last
one was just giant pile of crap mighty
died you son of a [ __ ] nevermind this
is all just a pile of crap yep Hey ha ha
there we go ok so I gotta kick it
farther and then be able to actually no
I actually don't need to get to get that
bar but I do I just need I just need to
be able to I don't know what I need to
be able to do oh hey come on but we can
make it
ya know it gets on bit Biff BAM [ __ ]
ok
I think the slow and methodical slow and
methodical there we go
got you okay now slighty ass mechanics
are gonna be the death of me I know this
I know this oh well mine then I gotta
jump up here I guess no oh that was
mistake huh huh there we go
yeah I'm away I made it I made it to the
exit actually go debug level does that
even mean Wow giggles what the hell whoa
giggles Wow he goes in here I go in here
looks like a thing that I could walk
into no belly burger
ah that's kind of weird what what I died
on what oh the spike okay well this is a
little strange
Gamow can I kill the Eagles thumb out
how much gonna be able to go through
there okay
okay all right we made it
I don't know if there's gotta be more
eagles but I made it through there yeah
oh come on yeah okay I don't know if
that's ketchup or blood I'm gonna assume
that it's ketchup butter ah come on
that's such bull kill dick god dingus
damn it knife niggles why do with hotdog
not like they're healthy I just gotta
wait until all the Eagles pass by or
something ah come on
this whole game is baloney okay I know
there's more oh come on what the hell
get out of here knife I don't want to
deal with you hey where are the other
Eagles the other heroes okay they're not
showing up apparently or something I
don't know I didn't see them yep yep
okay you go over there stab you kick you
in the balls here first
there we go now don't die from this
stupid ass pork oh come on ah ah ah so
dumb I wouldn't do that
why would I do that to me there's no
super why should you do the head so dumb
I hate this game
hate is so much don't die from the
flip-flopping on well I can't be the
flippers work oh my god I can't take
this watch come on such baloney
okay I know that a lot of you out there
gonna be like man dude game there
doesn't look so hard
you've flip-flopping the controls are
bad the physics are wonky and the jump
mechanics is sliding all over the place
and I don't like it so you you played
I'm not trying to fail here I like how I
have to justify my own failures oh come
on
ah this is a vine ball area
don't ask me why this is so hard cuz I
don't flip flap and no don't you dare
okay yeah that's right you walk away no
no no yeah fine fine
who's your jumpy the exit exit exit exit
good enough good enough good enough okay
we made it through another level ray-ray
for me I went on my webcam this game is
infuriating for all the wrong reasons
like it's uh it's just I want to talk
about it I didn't I'm done
one dark man I don't want him there we
go here yeah there we go okay let's just
get through this level
lickety-split kitty quick hey knock you
off your perch come on
oh come on whatever you know what I'll
go this way then cuz this is an option
boob oh it's such a condescending dick
voice there's a new name man fell into
my trap card
really you didn't wash up there you
didn't feel like dumping approach to
y'all button you were like you need to
do that we don't need to jump there I
can make that gap without jumping oh
good for you guys I was my fault
that's my fault I've called all the ones
that are my fault and then everything
else that I say is Bowl is the game
fault
I know when I messed up but this game
this game I blame everything else on why
am I not sprinting I'm holding down this
red button I'm holding it down
hey rolling it down rolling it down oh
good did I tell you you never been so
angry over a hot dog before and as an
American you'd think there would be
points at which I wasn't
oh that was my fault too that was also
my fault I I knew should have known that
the big blade would come thrashing at my
dog my dog you know my god now now [ __ ]
make it yeah it's too slippy slide e
it's like that other game that I was
playing that I hate you know the one
that I was playing for you guys is
enjoyment whatever it was called I don't
know one of those rage games Ted ah
gotcha was my boot my hot dog boot it
seriously is very slippy and slightly so
don't blame me don't blame me it's rare
oh no I needed that box where did it go
you see what I mean the box was there
and then he just vanished in a cloud of
ketchup in my I'm done with the day but
I'm done playing I'm all out of time my
time laying up I'm never playing it
again in my entire life so I hope you
all have a good life
I hope you got your last out your huh
huh huh mister chuckles out there live
in my misery whatever you know what I
don't care you have your own dime day oh
I'm gonna go celebrate Christmas in a
really bad mood
and then you all enjoy yourselves Oh
goodbye honey I'm doing my outro just by
[ __ ] it was almost on